so thank you very much for sticking
around it's my absolute pleasure to be
here for the inaugural gopher con this
talk is concurrency made easy if you
haven't no one's met me before my name
is Dave I as Audrey said I am a hubber
enthusiast and programmer from Sydney
and if I'm completely honest this slide
is here so that the timer starts in
keynote correctly so for my talk I want
to continue with the theme of
concurrency that some of the previous
speakers have touched on and as someone
who's had the privilege of talking to
programmers who are considering adopting
go I find that a common motivation
amongst many of them is the they want to
take advantage of this parallelism
that's inherent in our modern hardware
and similarly in in my self-appointed
role of a developer advocate when I meet
people who've learnt go one of the more
current things they say after they've
been writing go for a year or so kind of
things like this are you show of hands
does this resonate these quotes resonate
with anybody one person in the backyard
you're honest yeah okay
now if you won't go formally like what
maybe you've taken the training course
or you've studied it in a book you might
have noticed that the concurrency
section usually towards the back I mean
this is certainly true of my own
material so clearly there's a disconnect
between the concurrency primitives that
the language offers and the expectations
of some maybe many who come to language
for exactly those reasons I mean that
this kind of a dichotomy the headline
feature of go is our simple lightweight
concurrency model and as a product like
the language really sells itself
on this alone but on the other hand we
have this narrative that concurrency
isn't actually as easy to use as we make
out I mean otherwise authors and
trainees wouldn't make it the last
chapter in the book and we wouldn't look
back on our formative efforts
perhaps with regret and this is kind of
a shame because I I believe that the go
concurrency model is this one of the
simplest available and more importantly
the requirement for programmers to
embrace parallelism in available in our
hardware has never really been more
acute than it is now so what this is a
background I want to spend my time today
talking about some ideas that could make
concurrency easier to use not just for
newcomers but perhaps for all of us
so let's start in the obvious place I
mean we're talking about the go keyword
here is our simple web 2.0 hello world
program
show of hands just yell out can anyone
spot a problem with it at the back yell
it out
never exits okay close yeah pardon me
what yes there
this right here absolutely that's that's
right for is an infinite loop this empty
for loop so it's going to block the main
go routine because it doesn't do any IO
it doesn't wait on a lock we don't send
a receive on a channel or otherwise
communicate with the scheduler and as
the run time is we can say mostly
cooperatively scheduled this program is
going to spin fruitlessly on a single
CPU and maybe it'll end up live locking
the program it could starve the 13s
doing actual work so how could we fix
this here's one suggestion
I heard someone laughter in the back
that this is this is quite a common
solution I see that people come up with
and I think it's symptomatic of not
understanding the underlying problem now
if you're a little more experience with
go you might write something like this
the empty select here will block forever
I mean that's a useful property because
now we're not spinning a whole CPU just
to yield to the settler but as I said
before this is just treating the symptom
not the cause so I want to present to
you a different solution hopefully one
that's occurred to you already and that
is that rather than run listen and serve
in a goroutine leaving us with the
problem of what are we going to do with
the main go routine we simply run
listen serve ourself
so this is my first suggestion if you go
a teen can't make progress until it gets
the result of another oftentimes it's
going to be simpler to just do the work
yourself
this often coincides with eliminating a
lot of state and state tracking and
channel manipulation that is required to
plumb the result from that girl routine
back to yourself now I've chosen to make
this my first example because compared
to my next it's not only shorter but
perhaps it's more profound because many
go programmers overuse go routines
especially when they're starting out
now the previous example showed using a
go routine where one wasn't really
necessary but of course this is go and
one receives no points for doing only
one thing at a time and indeed there are
many instances where you want to exploit
the hardware parallelism you have
available to you and so to do that we
must use Gera teens now in this example
which is taken from a prior version of
GB vendor we're attempting to fetch a
set of dependencies in parallel so the
goal of this restore function is repose
represents a set of remote git repos
effectively and so we're trying to fetch
as many as we can in parallel now give
you a minute to look at this code does
it look reasonable
can you spot any problems
show of hands who thinks it's perfect
can anyone see a problem with it yeah
you do I yell it out
okay read from a closed channel we'll
come back to that as a code reviewer one
of the first things I'd be drawn to is
this interaction between this section
here where we're deferring the call to
wait group done and then we're receiving
a value of the semaphore and in the main
go routine we're waiting on that wait
group to be the incremented and then
we're closing a semaphore was that what
you noticed was that something else okay
so my question for you is the close of
this same channel happens after wait
group wait they happen in sequence so we
know that it happens afterwards and we
also know that the close of semaphore
happens after the call to wait group
done because this this statement won't
return until all the the wait groups
have been called done however this
received from the sim does not
necessarily happen before this so can
this can the close of Sam cause a panic
yes or no who thinks yes it could cause
a panic few people who thinks no even
less so as it happens no this can't
cause a panic one of two things will
happen either the receive from sim
happens before the close in which case
the receive from sim drains of value
from the channel and the market is
closed all the clothes of sim happens
first so what does receiving from a
closed channel return anyone I heard a
few people say zero value when does it
return it how long does it take
immediately right now the point of
talking about this is that what turns
out that these are these two these two
outcomes are both safe we had to spend
some time thinking about it the logic
here in this code is unnecessary and
necessarily confusing so if we simplify
the defer statement and reorder the
operations we get something like this
now there's no question in which order
the operations are going to occur in the
program at the top we add to the wait
group and then each time through the
loop we push your value onto the
semaphore
when the go routine is done we take a
very off the semaphore and will reduce
the weight group count and then in the
main go team we're just waiting on that
that weight group count to drop to zero
so now there's no ambiguity what's going
on so the suggestion that I draw from
this example is always release blocks
and semaphores in the reverse order that
you took them at best mixing up the
order as we saw previously generates
kind of confusing code we have to think
about it we have to think we have to
reason through all the possible states
and at worst mixing acquire and release
logic is a is a sure path to deadlocks
so now we've rearranged the program a
little we can ask another question what
is the reason for closing the semaphore
channel I mean if a restaurant closes it
doesn't remove anyone seated that at the
tape at the table it's just an
indication the restaurant isn't taking
any new passengers so any any new
customers so similarly channels are not
resources like files and networks or
sockets the closed signal doesn't free
your channel it just marks that channel
is no longer accepting new values now in
our example nothing is waiting in a
select or a range loop for that closed
signal so we can just remove the clothes
the clothes are semaphore it's not
necessary
so closing a channel is a signal to its
receivers that it's no longer accepting
new data little more closing your
channel isn't necessary to free a
channel you don't need to close a
channel to clean it up and speaking
simmer semaphores look a bit closer at
how Sam is used
so the role of Sam is to make sure that
at any one time there's a cap on the
number of fetch operations running we
don't want to start them all at once we
want to gate them when I gave this talk
when I gave this talk in Melbourne I
said the number four was probably about
as much as the Australian Internet could
take but if you look closely Sam isn't
guaranteeing that there are no more than
four fetch fetch operations running it's
actually doing something else can
anybody spot it yes at the back correct
so rather than guaranteeing there no
more four operations running it's
actually stopping there being any more
than four guru teens running at one time
so assuming there enough phase in repose
let's just assume that there is quite a
few to fetch each time through the loop
we're going to try and push the number
one on to the same channel and then we
fire off a fetch go routine so what
happens when we get to the fifth
iteration in this loop it's quite likely
that we'll have four goroutines running
or at least have been scheduled to run
there's no guarantee by the scheduler
that a go routine is run immediately or
put on a backlog so there'll be four
already in train but on the fifth
iteration the main loop is going to
block here before we start the go
routine until there are space in the
semaphore channel to push another value
so rather than spawning Len of repos
number of goroutines and letting them
fight it out amongst themselves for a
semaphore this loop is actually going to
proceed at the rate at which fetch
operation is complete now it doesn't
matter so much in this example because
the whole of restore blocks until we
fetched all of the repos that we need
but there are many situations where the
calling code expects to be able to set
up this work to happen in the background
properly and then return
so the most straightforward solution to
me is to move the taking of the
semaphore inside the go routine so now
all the fetch go teens will be created
straightaway we just go through this for
loop very quickly creating those guru
teens and they'll negotiate amongst
themselves for a place on the seventh
floor channel and so a recommendation
from this perhaps could be that although
guru teens are cheap to create and
schedule the resources they operate on
files sockets bandwidth disk i/o are
often scarce err this pattern of using a
channel as a semaphore to limit
work-in-progress is quite common but to
make sure that you're not unduly
blocking the code trying to offload that
work a good idea is to acquire the serf
or when you're ready to use it not when
you expect to use it
so hopefully we've got all the bugs out
of this program however there is one
more obvious one that I haven't talked
about and it's quite a serious one that
I think catches almost all go
programmers out at least once
Kenny one spot it
okay yeah
okay that's not the answer but I'll come
back to that yep at the back right
exactly the variable repo in our for
loop here is being captured by this
anonymous go team here that that
variable repo and this one are the same
variable so as you said each time
through the loop we're going to be
updating the value of repo so most
likely all those goroutines are going to
end up fetching just the final value and
as you spotted more importantly this is
a data race because we have one girl
routine up here changing the value of
repo and we have many others reading it
concurrently this is that the textbook
definition of a data race
now this is one of the classical paper
cuts which I think many of us have
learnt the hard way
and you might think that rewriting the
program like this would solve it so it's
show hands if I fix the race no one's
gonna fall fair how I not fixed the race
exactly why is that just yell it out
exactly it's the same thing rather than
kept closing over repos I'm just closing
it over the value of I which is going to
be incremented in the loop now I'm going
to go out on a limb here and say in my
opinion the cause of this common error
is the interaction of three things
anonymous functions lexical closure and
goroutines and it's the combination or
all three is nothing wrong with these
features by themselves but it's the
combination now it's really cute to be
able to write an anonymous function and
execute it in line like we do here but
then the reader has to consider the
effect of lexical closure and something
else that seems to challenge quite a
number of programmers that come to go is
this idea of nested scopes
so instead what we have to do is ensure
that a unique value of repo or I
whichever we choose is passed to each
fetcher routine when they're invoked
this is there's a bunch of ways to do it
this is one so now there's a new repo
declared inside the go routine and we
just passed the ice value of repo to it
so a recommendation that I draw from
this is avoid mixing anonymous functions
and goroutines an apply my own advice
replace the anonymous function with a
named one and pass all the variables
variables to it that we need this is not
a very pithy example because it's work
work we're working from one place to
another so there is quite a lot of
parameters passed there but the result
is that we've eliminated the possibility
of lexical capture and so we've been
eliminated that data race it just can't
happen
well we know the answer so after this
review we've refactored the code to make
a clean separation between the function
that's producing the work our restore
function and the function is actually
processing that work now called worker
so we fixed all the issues with this
code I've heard two heard two people say
something so there's at least one or two
left let's have a look at the the core
of the worker function that's calling
fetch and handling the error right there
can anyone see a problem with this
I think someone yelled it out before you
were down the down the back yes
it's not about the clothes channel I
think you had
okay so for the recording what would
happen if more than one say say the
networking just went down not here at
Google but perhaps in Australia and all
the fetchers failed at once what's
what's going to happen someone said
deadlock yeah so each of the error is
not going to be nil and so each of these
guru teens is going to try and push an
error onto the error channel to report
what's happened let's have a look at the
declaration of error Chen
what's its capacity just one but our
semaphore channel has capacity of four
so it's going to be at least four jobs
running at once so we could have up to
four of them trying to write is that
actually crate could there be up to four
how many how many possible error values
could we have to send here over here the
number of repos yes every single one of
them can fail
not
okay I'll come back to that so as as
someone said over there this is going to
lead to a deadlock because we if we
can't push on to the arrow channel we
can't push on to the arrow channel we
can't release the semaphore we can't
release wait group done and so we can't
restore can't return so I want to
introduce this idea that before you
start a goroutine you should always
think about how and when it will exit
and how do we go about applying this
advice to the example um I like to do it
by working backwards and ask what ways
this go routine can exit in this example
it's pretty simple we know that the go
team starts with the worker function so
when worker exits when worker returns
the NGO a team will exit now because
this function contains a defer even
though this statement occurs first we'll
consider it as the last statement if
there are multiple defers you consider
them with a last in first out strategy
wait group done is a single signal to
the wait group which is another kind of
semaphore that the task is done wait
group done never blocks so the statement
will not prevent the worker returning
the penultimate statement is is receive
from Sam which can't block because we
couldn't get to this point unless we've
been able to push a number one on to
that semaphore channel now the value
that we take off that channel may not be
our number one there may be somebody
else's but we are guaranteed to receive
a value so this statement won't block so
this just leaves us with the call to
fetch and for argument's sake let's
assume it's well written it has
appropriate timeouts it is guaranteed to
return at some point now if there's no
error from fetch we're not going to
enter the if condition and so we're
going to drop down to the semaphore
which we've talked about go to the defer
we're done this is going to exit cleanly
if there is an error you must place it
onto the error chan before we can go
through this exit behavior so if we want
this to always succeed what is the
capacity we should give to err Chan
someone set it down down the back
earlier it's got to be the line of
repose
as I said it's got to be the learn every
post this at least guarantee that if
every fetch were to fail they'll be
capacity to store the error without
deadlocking
however there is another option now if
you look here we see that restore only
returns one error value which it reads
from the error Qian on the last line so
rather than creating space for all
possible errors we can just use this
behavior of the caller to say we only
want to handle the first error the first
one that happens for some conditioner
first so if there if the error is not
nil we try to push it on to the error
Qian but if that operation would block
we fall through to the default behavior
and just discard it there probably a
bunch of different ways you would handle
this strategy in your own code and it
really depends on how you propagate that
error up you might merge it into some
multi area you might choose to return a
slice of error as it really depends but
in this case we know that Restorick is
only capable of returning one value so
anything that happens after that first
error we can just discard
and as a bonus question which will
answer in the questions the read from
error Chan in restore is guaranteed to
never block even if all calls to fetch
succeed how does this work you can
answer me after the questions
so the name of this talk is concurrency
made easy
it's my nod to rich hickies fantastic
paper simple made easy which rich Hickey
demonstrates that the the ideas of easy
and simple and not synonyms they're in
fact completely orthogonal and given
that I've just spent the last 20 minutes
discussing six bugs in a 20 line program
I don't think I can argue in any in any
way that concurrency is simple a
concurrent system is inherently more
complex than a sequential one
now what I've pitched you today are not
patents to be applied in specific cookie
cutter situations instead what I want
you to take away from this presentation
a general suggestions that I've
Illustrated principles if I can be so
bold the principles not rules or
patterns principles which give you a
framework to answer your own questions
when you're writing concurrent programs
and hopefully by applying these
principles you can make your time
writing concurrent code if not easy at
least hopefully a little easier thank
you very much
[Applause]